The
care must be provided to us at the Center for Equality of
have to be in the Center and as a society of
we have to be
capable of launching 1 Big change
also in this area.
Just think that at this moment this is not possible.
because we have thus raised 15 years of 1 government
D.O. popular party
what or give us to eh 1 model where we do not invite
people or models must be
that people can pass into their avellet
not at home,
that the residence
ten to be the last resort ten to candles
they have to be of quality eh
we have to bet on 1 public system
that guarantees equality in or access,
but we know what other objective has to be,
1 active beauty,
that people have
resources and are well maintained
nashis houses.
It is not an easy challenge,
but it is objective that we have to set ourselves
in this legislature,
because either we think big or anonymously of being capable
to move forward and backward
these years
where we see how the elderly did not antiveron
attention they need eh deserve